[音楽]
早速ですが皆さんに一つのチャレンジをしてもらいましょう
皆さん一人一人に考えてもらいます
今私があなたのところに行けるように道案内をしてみてください
どうでしょうか
考えられましたか
難しいですよね
なぜならあなたは私の現在地を知りませんしクルマに乗れるか
交通機関はあるかなどの必要な情報が不足しているからです
そんな状況で道案内をしていただいたとしても私が道に迷うことは確実でしょ
私は歩き回ってヘッドヘッドになってしまいます
そんな私に対してあなたはとにかく頑張れって言うしかありません
私はうんざりして公開するでしょ何をどうやって頑張ればいいの
これは私が関わっているあった障害やそれにいた困りごとがある子どもたちの状態を
表した例え話です
発達障害とは生まれつきの脳機能の発達の偏りによるものでその人の得意不得意の特性
とその人が過ごす環境や周りの人との関わりとも椅子まっちーによって社会生活に混乱
が発生する障害です
私の大学院時代の指導教官だった京都大学霊長類研究所シュッ急所
正高教授は自閉症スペクトラムと呼ばれているような障害は実は障害ではない
生物としての人類のバリエーションの一つであると述べられています
私は生涯ではなくバリエーションとして捉えるという考え方に感銘を受けました
一般的に発達障害と呼ばれたりそれにいた困りごとがある人たちのことを私は得意と
苦手の差が大きい
凸凹の人と捉えています
大学院から子どもの学習支援の研究に室に今は学習に困りごとがある子どもたちを支援
するために npo で教室を運営しています
私が関わっている子どもたちは機ほどのたとえ話のように様々な場面で自分らしさを
見失い
迷い途方に暮れています
今日は迷子になっていた2人の子どもとの関わりについてお話をしていきます
1人目の男の子の特性は読むことはスムーズにできますが漢字を書くことは何度練習し
てもできません
いわゆる学習障害の1つですその特性と周りの要求とのミスマッチによってストレスが
非常に大きくてうつ病も発症しているほどでした
彼は学校には行っておらず家でほとんどゲームをして過ごしていました
親の口癖はゲームはやめなさい
そんなことよりも英単語の一つでも覚えなさいでした
初めて会った日お母さんと教室に一緒に入ってきた彼は真っ青な顔をしていました
私は何度か彼を安心させたくて無理はしなくていい
あなたはそのままで大丈夫と伝えました
お母さんはホッとした表情で押されていました
でもその男の子はどんどん表情がこわばっていき
震えてずっと下を向いていました
私は次に彼た牛道の日まであの子はどんな言葉が欲しかったんだろうと考え続けました
彼は自己紹介で僕は勉強ができません
テストはいつも最低です何も分かりません
何もしたくありませんと言いました
会話のきっかけを探していて彼が水辺の生き物が描かれた下敷きを持っていたので
先生も川の生き物昔たくさん買ってたんだよという話をすると
この犬山市にも彼はにたくさん外来種がいるんですと生き物のことを生き生きと話して
くれました
こんなに話す子だったのかと驚きました
リラックスしてくると
僕が家でゲームばかりしてたのは暇だったからです
好きなことを話してもそんなことよりも勉強しなさいって言われるから
好きなこともできなかったと言っていました
初めて会った日私が彼に伝えた
そのままでいいわあ
自分らしさを見失い迷子になっている彼に対して
迷子のままでいいんだよと言っているようなものでした
でも今度はあなたは書くのは苦手でもそんなことより生き物が大好きで詳しいよねと
言いました
今自分はどんなことに興味があって
な得意なことがあるのか
自分はどんな存在かを確かめることができ
彼は僕は生き物に関わる仕事がしたいですと言ってくれました
このこのように私がかかわる子どもたちはみんな素直で
回っ大人たちも子どものことを考えて一生懸命にサポートされていました
しかし子供たちは次第に自信を失い
迷子になっていきます
これは子どもサポートする上である視点が欠けているからだと考えています
私は子供から大人まで凸凹の人に関する相談をたくさん受けます
その中で
あの子はあれもできませんこれもできませんどうしたらいいですかという相談が
ほとんどです
その相談者にその子の別の情報ありますかと聞くとできないこと以外の情報が出てき
ません
そこに得意なことを生かそうとする視点がないんです
苦手なことを改善させようと必死になるあまりその後本来の姿を半分も愛でていないん
です
その後に関する情報が不足するためできるアドバイスは目標に届くまで頑張れ
しかありません
失敗が続き自分の好きなことや得意なことも認めてもらえず自分らしさを見失い
迷子になってしまいます
しかし先ほどもう男の子のように
彼の好きなことや得意なことを止め
それがかけがえのない素晴らしいものであることを伝えたことで彼は自分ださに気づく
ことができました
しなければいけないという焦りから解放されて
僕はこんなことも出来るというワクワクした気持ちを私と共有してくれました
それから彼は自分らしく進んでいくことができています
二人目の子はものすごく小さな字を書く女の子でした
その子も先ほどの男の子と同じで読むことはスムーズにできますが漢字を書くことは何
度練習してもできません
彼女は多いました
何度練習して書いても間違いを指摘されるから違いがわからないぐらい小さい字を書く
のと
彼女も自分を見失い迷子の状態でした
彼女が迷子から抜け出すきっかけになったのは悔しくてくっしゃくさにされていた
15点の英語の答案よしでした
一緒に見てみるとリスニングはほとんど取れていました
すごい聞き取ること得意じゃんかと伝えるとその子はホッとした本表情していました
ある日彼女は方いました
学校の授業でもとを書いていると書くことで頭がいっぱいになって聞くことに集中でき
なくなるからもうノートは書かないと
そこで私はこうお願いしました
じゃああなたが頑張って聞いてきたことをこれから先生に聞かせて欲しいと
それから彼女は楽しそうに授業で聞いてきたことを語り
私は聞くという勉強が始まりました
しばらくして彼女はまたこう言いました
清永先生に伝えるのにやっぱり言葉だけじゃ足りないから
ノートも書いてみたいと
そこから彼女は創意工夫を凝らしたノートを作るようになり自分が読むために
字も大きくなっていきました
時の間違いの多さは以前と変わりませんが
苦手さを隠すようなことはもうしません
誰かに伝えたいと願いが込められたの音は素晴らしいものでしたね
迷子になっていた彼女は聞くことが自分の得意なことであることに気がつきました
それから水を得た魚のように自分の得意を生かした学びを作っていきました
社会に適応するためだけに作られた目標ではなく
自分を知り自分の特徴が切る目標立て
頑張りました
そこから得たものは勉強だけにとどまりません
彼女は人生のいろいろな場面において迷子になることなく進んでいけるでしょう
自分にワクワクするための自分らしさに気づける
素晴らしい
この言葉が迷子になっている子供たちが自分らしさに気づける後押しをします
子どもだけでなく迷子になったまま大人になった人もいます
あなたの近くにそんな子どもや大人はいませんか
迷子になっている彼らが本当に欲しい言葉は
そのままでいいでもなく頑張ればできる
でもなく
あなたのここが素晴らしいです
今からでも遅くはありませんそう伝えてみてください
その一言でその人は救われるでしょう
それぞれが自分らしさに気付きこんなこともできる
とワクワクした笑顔にあふれる社会
こんなワクワクした映画を見てみるとあなたもそうありたいと思いませんか
こんな笑顔があふれる社会
それが私が子どもたちや
あなたと一緒に実現したい社会です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]